dos barcos de guerra cara a cara uno es
taiwanés el otro chino cada uno de ellos
está listo para disparar en cualquier
momento un claro indicio de las altas
tensiones entre las dos potencias en el
estrecho de Taiwán la televisión Estatal
china anunció el sábado simulacros
militares a gran escala del ejército
chino donde se movilizaron 71 aviones
militares y nueve buques de guerra
el objetivo ensayar un cerco completo de
Taiwán situado sobre 130 kilómetros de
la costa China
Taiwán es una parte inseparable de China
desde el final de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial china se niega a reconocer la
independencia de Taiwán y considera La
Isla como parte de su propio territorio
una alianza que quedó patente a
principios de semana durante la visita
la presidenta taiwanesa California para
reunirse con el presidente de la cámara
de representantes
su presencia y apoyo tranquiliza al
pueblo de Taiwán no nos sentimos solos
el apoyo de Estados Unidos a Taiwán es
un desafío para china ya que tiene
muchas bases militares en la región y ha
dicho que estaría dispuesto a defender a
Taiwán invadir a la isla el presidente
chino ha dicho que la reunificación con
Taiwán debe cumplirse lo que hace temer
que puede usar la fuerza el riesgo a
corto plazo de una invasión es bajo y a
día de hoy no hay señales ni pruebas de
que china se esté preparando para ello
sin embargo china sigue aumentando
significativamente sus capacidades
militares para tener más poder en los
próximos años lo que podría cambiar el
status quo y permitirle tomar Taiwán por
la fuerza
según Beijing los ejercicios militares
durarán tres días en total